that's the secret I've been hiding all
along all the Dragon Ball releases suck
for let's talk Dragon Ball there
in here is usually called the Blue
bricks and while the commenter is
correct that they are at least not zoom
crop to widescreen the visual Fidelity
especially in the color department is
pretty bad on these releases crushed
dark detailed wacky colors the whole
nine yards then we have GT of which even
its original Japanese release is married
with an awful red wash making Super
Saiyan 4's fur look pink then lastly we
have Kai and while the first part of Kai
is arguably the best release the show
has ever seen the buark otherwise known
as Kai the final chapters is somehow the
worst release Dragon Ball has
seen zoomed to widescreen aggressive
noise removal that messes with the line
art and worst of all the entire show is
covered in an insane green filter